la vie d'un animal totem celle d'un
humain
ça c'est la grosse question la question
que ça pose en fait c'est de savoir s'il
y a une exception de l'espèce humaine
par rapport au reste du monde animal et
je pense effectivement qu'il faut garder
comme point de mire disons l'idée que
l'espèce humaine
elle est une et indivisible et qu'il ya
un respect à avoir qu'ils soient absolus
de toutes les vies humaines
après ça va pas dire qu'il faille abuser
des vies animales
je pense que les animaux qui ont un
droit absolu à vivre ce sont les animaux
sauvages qui sont aujourd'hui dans un
déclin qui absolument terrible donc je
serai par exemple pour le fait
d'interdire les chasse notamment en
afrique
après se pose la question est évidemment
de savoir comment on traite les animaux
que malgré tout on va mettre l'élevage
autorise le fait d'abattre des animaux
je pense qu'il faut rester dans ce
système là malgré tout puisque les
animaux on le sait peuvent avoir du
stress mais ils n'ont pas une conscience
de la mort notamment comme les humains
peuvent la voir
donc je pense que là où il faut être
absolument vigilant ce sont les
conditions de vie de ces animaux qui
doivent respecter vraiment la façon dont
il le m'arrache la façon qu'ils ont peur
de dormir la façon dont six socialistes
entre eux et ensuite leur apporter une
fin de vie qui n'est pas le but de leur
vie mais qui en est vraiment le denon
[Musique]